[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le jeudi 30 décembre
voici les titres j - avant le réveillon
de la saint sylvestre l'occasion de se
mettre à table pour un bon repas si vous
avez encore des doutes sur les produits
nos conseils dans cette édition pour vos
choix de fromages et de boissons avec
deux enseignes à montigny le bretonneux
et maurepas après lady neko que défaite
33 % des français disent vouloir faire
du sport comme bonne résolution quels
exercices pratiqués pour détoxifier son
corps nous sommes allés poser la
question à coach sportif de versailles
et puis en parlant de sport elle est à
16 ans la championne de france cadette
actuel de cross jade le corps a remporté
la distinction en novembre dernier à
montauban licencié à l'entente
athlétique de saint quentin en yvelines
elle est un grand espoir de sa
discipline mais avant de développer ses
titres de la politique avec les
élections présidentielles qui approche à
quatre mois du premier tour la candidate
les républicains valérie pécresse a
nommé six porte parole pour sa campagne
trois femmes et trois hommes avec une
moyenne d'âge de 38 en libye noise a
notamment choisi un élu de son
département othman rookie et vice
président de la région île de france
mais aussi conseiller municipal
d'opposition dans la ville de trappes il
nous livre sa réaction dans cette
interview express
c'est une immense fierté d'avoir été
nommé porte-parole de valérie pécresse
candidate à l'élection présidentielle
parce que c'est quelqu'un qui a montré
ce qu'elle savait faire à la tête de la
région ile-de-france qu'elle savait
faire comme ministre est alors le
privilège de porter sa parole pour
expliquer aux français durant et un peu
plus de trois mois que va durer cette
élection présidentielle cette campagne
ce qu'elle compte faire pour le pays
pourquoi est-ce que c'est essentiel qu
elle soit notre prochaine président de
la république c'est évidemment une
immense responsabilité j'en suis très
honoré
un porte parole est là pour relayer les
propositions de son de sa candidate et
dans une campagne qui vont plus être
très courte qui je l'espère va pouvoir
quand même avoir lieu normalement avec
un débat démocratique de qualité malgré
la crise sanitaire est donc cette équipe
de porte-parole hélas pour démultiplier
les propositions des explications les
débats afin que tous les français
connaissent la vision le projet de
valérie pécresse qui est un projet de
franche rupture et un projet pour aller
au bout des réformes dans le pays a
besoin et pour changer le quotidien des
français
[Musique]
alors trois femmes trois hommes et un
yvelinois et j'ai cet immense privilège
d'être livres chinois de cette équipe en
l'occurrence qui est une équipe
effectivement avec un vrai
renouvellement ça ce n'est pas nouveau
chez valérie pécresse sa capacité à
rassembler d'abord des sensibilités très
différentes à les faire travailler
ensemble et aussi à renouveler a montré
aussi de nouveaux visages à donner sa
chance à de nouveaux profils et ça je
crois que c'est bien d'avoir à la fin
l'expérience et le renouvellement et
c'est pour cela aussi qu'elle est aussi
crédible dans cette élection
présidentielle
[Musique]
quelques jours après la prise de parole
du premier ministre et avec un taux
d'incidence frôlant les 1000 cas pour
100000 habitants dans le département le
préfet des yvelines prend de nouvelles
mesures à compter de ce 31 décembre le
port du masque sera désormais
obligatoire à l'extérieur dans
l'ensemble des communes du 78 quelques
exceptions pour les personnes en
situation de handicap à d'obligations
non plus pour les moins de 11 ans les
personnes pratiquant une activité
sportive les cyclistes ou les personnes
circulant également à moto dans un
véhicule autre décision importante la
consommation d'alcool sur la voie
publique sera interdit de vendredi soir
à lundi matin les activités de danse
dans les établissements recevant du
public seront prohibés tous les soirs du
31 décembre et jusqu'au 3 janvier enfin
dans les bars et restaurants 1 fermeture
obligatoire à 2 heures du matin maximum
pour les soirées du premier du 2 et du 3
janvier pour le réveillon du nouvel an
vous pourrez tout de même vous mettre à
table avec prudence afin de ravir vos
papilles et celle de vos convives qui
al'idée de fromage ou de boissons pour
votre repas et justine brasier mathy de
franck ou céline charles et nicolas
landry y ont goûté quelques produits
pour vous chez deux commerçants yvelines
ont regardé à la preuve du réveillon
nous vous proposons de découvrir
quelques commerçants locaux et des idées
pour vos repas de fin d'année et oui on
va aller découvrir deux boutiques
différentes moi je vais me rendre vienne
bibard à maurepas entre vins champagne
ou encore bière je pense qu'on va avoir
plusieurs choses à découvrir et à
découvrir et consommer avec modération
bien sûr et vous justin je crois qu'on
va vous retrouver au rayon fromage si
c'est bien ça exactement céline et j'y
vais de ce pas
[Musique]
je
je me trouve à la fromagerie les petites
souris à montigny le bretonneux et je
suis accompagné de muriel dirige vous
êtes la fromagère bon jour en jour donc
vous avez créé la boutique un peu pour
faire redécouvrir un autre patrimoine
français qu'est le fromage et vous
sélectionnez vos produits auprès de
petits producteurs c'est bien ça j'ai
créé ma boutique il y a deux ans avant
le confinement je sélectionne donc mes
fromages -près de petits producteurs
avec qui je suis en collaboration toutes
les semaines pour sélectionner les
fromages les meilleurs de sélection tout
ce qui est à la truffe ou lait crus
c'est bien super est-ce que déjà pouvez
nous parler un peu vos produits phares
alors mes produits phares pour les fêtes
on a un ventre et du coup au mois
d'octobre une tomme de brebis au lait
cru ou celui ci c'est ça qui a fini dans
du foie dans les pyrénées donc ce qui
donne au bout de les brebis un doigt
seydoux d'accord on a également le
parisien aux truffes et luc existe aussi
au lait cru mais que je sorte russe
puisque je ne suis pas son truc mais
après ça on a le délice de vulcain qui
ressemble à
vulcain par rapport au volcan sicilien
de l'allier et celui ci est un chef
passe et crémeux à s'étendre c'est bien
peut-être est-ce que l'on peut goûter un
peu tout ça ça m'a donné on peut y a pas
de souci j'espère je vous suis alors
donc on a un aux trois fromages comment
va se passer la dégustation alors pour
une dégustation généralement commence du
moins fort au plus fort d'accord on va
commencer par le délice de vulcain allez
je vous laisse déguster ouais donc là
ils sont un petit peu près parce qu'il
vient de sortir du frigo qui permet dans
le démon basque
espère t on
c'est encore un petit peu froid parce
qu'il sort du frigo normalement pour les
sortir une heure avant pour la
dégustation d'accord un site où on va
avoir du coup la tonne qui a fini hors
du froid donc c'est normal qu'elle un
peu de fond dessus puisqu'elle est
vraiment embrouillé dans le foie
d'accord on le laisse de succès pour la
présentation vous pouvez les décès
dessus de ma croûte ce manche donc une
croûte naturelle après ça on peut
enlever la peau pour manger bien sûr on
mange pas le point vie n'ont
donc la coupe se mange c'est ça
mais ce superbe où ça c'est d'où la
larme à gauche ouais c'est vrai pas
après c'est vraiment il a eu la médaille
d'or au mondial des fromages autres
étant d'accord bah voila je suis super
qualité
on va avoir le parisien truffé
alors tenté bien le truc c'est pour ça
qu'on les emballe dans l'est dans la
vitrine pour pas qu'il se passera mais
hassa sur la truffe
c'est puissant allez je vous de ça
une chose est sûre un triple crème
cent fois enrichi entraîne donc un peu
plus caloriques
je crois que c'est mon préféré
il est super bon pas pris on n'a pas
l'habitude de manger forcément des idées
propagées la trouve comme ça non pour
relever la place à ceux qui n'aiment pas
trop relevé on a de la truffe d'été qui
est moins forte on a d'autres leaders
pour ceux qui ont vraiment la truite qui
prend vraiment la saveur du fromage on a
de tout et écouter notre dégustation est
terminée moi je vais quand même finir
mon fromage merci vous en tout cas
variable de nous avoir reçus donc voila
moi je pense que j'ai trouvé mon fromage
pour la fin d'année et puis céline
j'imagine que vous aussi vous avez à des
propositions à nous faire pour cette fin
d'année en tout cas pour les repas
effectivement justin je pense vous
trouvez quelque chose de sympa je me
trouve jolie angie bar à maurepas
aujourd'hui avec son gérant eric abibal
c'est ça bonjour bonjour et bienvenue
aux ennemis est-ce que vous pouvez nous
présenter un petit peu le concept du
coup dans cet endroit bien sûr donc on
est un concept de
deux caves donc vente à emporter
on vend des vins de la bière des
spiritueux et on a une partie bar
événementiel et donc je sais que vous
faites bières vins champagne c'est un
peu difficile de s'y retrouver des fois
est-ce que vous pouvez nous proposer une
petite sélection de vins pour le nouvel
an parce que là la soirée arrive et je
crois que beaucoup de personnes voudront
savoir ce que vous nous avez fait pareil
pour commencer je vous ai proposé enfin
je vous propose un chardonnay vin blanc
cépage chardonnay blanc très très fruité
très beurré vraiment d'une grande
finesse ça va très bien se marier avec
une entrée un poisson ça va se voir
également en apéritif peut pas faire non
plus fêté fêter la fin d'année sans
boire une coupe de champagne évidemment
donc j'ai sélectionné un champagne de
propriété le charme meyreuil un blanc de
noirs un champagne brut mais c'est avec
une certaine sucrosité c'est vraiment
très fin aussi donc idéal pour fêter les
fêter la fin d'année avec ça et ben je
crois qu'avec ça on est pas trop mal et
moi par contre j'aime beaucoup le foie
gras alors est ce que vous auriez des
conseils pour une bonne boisson qui peut
accompagner le foie gras j'ai fait une
sélection de 2,20
légèrement sucré notamment un jurançon
qui est un vin de
une appellation des pyrénées si on
n'aime pas forcément les vins trop
sucrés on peut aussi manger un foie gras
avec un vin d'alsace un gears 3 mineurs
moi ça m'a donné envie de goûter je sais
pas vous mais en tout cas on va passer à
la dégustation avec plaisir donc là je
vois les deux bouteilles dont vous
m'avez parlé tout à l'heure de vin
parfaitement adapté pour servir avec un
foie gras ben je vous propose de le
déguster eh ben on va goûter ça tout de
suite je me permets d'en de masques
[Musique]
il est suspecté sucre et là on est
vraiment dans mon côté bouée lollichon
pas ce que voulait dire avec le foie
gras à mon avis ça va parfaitement
convenir ça fait penser un peu à la
confiture con mais avec le foie gras des
fois oui il ya ce côté un peu compotée
sa voix la confiture effectivement ça ce
registre est bien une confiture de
figues du foie gras c'est parfait et le
deuxième du coup c'est vous m'avez dit
que c'est un vin pour un vin alsacien
cépages donc le sais pas chez les
raisins qui utilise un plus fort en goût
fort oui un petit peu plus marqué en
moins - le côté sucré
[Musique]
donc les gamers très mineur cd20 très
fruité avec des notes un peu de fruits
jaunes a coûté très vif et très
aromatique voilà ça permet d'avoir un
côté très très acidulé également avec un
foie gras sans avoir le côté sucré trop
marquée c'est parfait c'est les vins
d'alsace on les voit toujours ou au
moment à cette période de fêtes est-ce
que vous avez un petit conseil pour
savoir comment reconnaître un bon ou un
bon vin parce que je conseille surtout
au moment de choisir un vin c'est de
regarder millésime en fonction des
régions il ya des vins qui peuvent se
garder d'autres plus ou moins longtemps
voilà il ya des années qui sont
intéressantes d'autres moins en tout cas
pour les mises en garde
mais toujours l'importance de se faire
conseiller par son caviste notamment je
crois que mon préféré sera celui là
d'accord écoutez le choix est fait pour
pour le réveillon celui ci pourrait
merci nous avons réussi merci à vous
avec grand plaisir et à très bientôt aux
ennemis en tout cas justin nous voilà
bien équipé pour le nouvel an quand à
vous on espère vous avoir donné quelques
idées en attendant passer de bonnes
fêtes on vous rappelle bien sûr que
l'alcool est à consommer avec modération
et si vous avez prévu de vous déplacer
dans la soirée de la saint-sylvestre le
réseau des transports fonctionnera en
partie toute la nuit en ile-de-france
certains métros et bus mais aussi rer
tramway et transilien et noctilien
resteront opérationnelles même après les
horaires classiques de fin de service
dans les yvelines vous le voyez sont
concernés les rer à b et c mais aussi
les lignes j ai les e du transilien plus
et villes sont éloignés de la capitale -
il y à deux fréquences de passage selon
votre gare compter en moyenne entre 30
minutes et une heure entre chaque train
certaines portions seront également
limitées à quelques trains seulement
dans la nuit toutes les informations sur
le site et d'ile-de-france mobilité qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran avec les
repas de fêtes de fin d'année et copieux
les français prennent en moyenne un kilo
et demi pour les perdre très rapidement
quoi de mieux que l'activité physique et
sportive un coach sportif versaillais
vous livre justement ces conseils pour
détoxifier votre corps notre reportage
avec michael et demi dont
33 pour cent des français inscrits comme
première bonne résolution pour 2022
faire du sport plus régulièrement un
moyen efficace pour détoxifier son corps
après l'abondance des repas de fête
l'activité physique va vous aider à vous
sentir mieux que j'ai pensé ça va être
des exercices qui vont être très simple
ça va être commencer par des exercices
cardio donc ça va être déjà dans un
premier temps se mettre en marche si on
voit qu'on n'a pas assez de résultats a
pas assez d'intensité on va y aller
progressivement sur de la course pour
avoir l'envié d'aller plus loin dans
dans son entraînement ajoutez ensuite du
renforcement musculaire le traditionnel
gainage en veillant à garder une bonne
posture sans lever les fesses trop des
pompes pour les plus courageux ou encore
les célèbres squatte une flexion des
jambes très efficace pour brûler la
graisse des exercices simples et
fonctionnelle en ajoutant au fil des
semaines intensité et difficultés on va
commencer avec deux à trois fois par
semaine à l'idée c'est de prendre goût
au sport goût à l'activité physique et
dès qu'on a pris goût on peut augmenter
la fréquence en y ajoutant divers
disciplines un toujours varié ses
entraînements pour pas habitué son corps
à un type d'effort un maître mot la
progressivité quand le quand on n'est
pas habitué à l'effort mieux vaut
commencer en douceur l'astuce ça va être
deux il y aller progressivement c'est
par exemple sur la course on l'a on
entend souvent faut courir une heure 45
minutes pour ça soit efficace moi je
vais vous conseiller de courir cinq
minutes ça va vous donner confiance en
vous et par la suite on termine sur de
la marche donc vous allez avoir une
sortie en extérieur d'une heure par
exemple avec un peu de course et la fois
d'après on va augmenter on va passer sur
dix minutes 15 minutes et ainsi de suite
une détox sportive a pratiqué chez vous
ou en salle ce studio a ouvert depuis
avril dernier dans le centre ville de
versailles il propose des séances avec
les conseils d'un coach sportif qui peut
venir également à domicile compter entre
30 et 60 euros le cours au travail
du football avec la coupe de france et j
moins 3 avant les seizièmes de finale
versailles reçoit la roche sur yon ce
dimanche j'ai regardé les maillots sont
prêts ils ont été préparés hier avec le
flocage du logo du fcv 78 notre seule et
fiers représentants yvelinois une
qualification en huitièmes de finale de
la compétition serait une première dans
l'histoire du club coup d'envoi ce
dimanche à 13h45 au stade mont boron
l'entrée sera de 10 euros billets
achetés et dimanche directement sur
place la rencontre est également à
suivre à distance sur eurosport player
tous derrière bien sûr les versaillais
t le 14 novembre dernier à montauban le
titre de championne de france cadette de
cross jade le corps est licencié du club
de l'entente athlétique de saint quentin
en yvelines à 16 ans la jeune yvelinoise
est un grand espoir de sa discipline son
portrait par céline charles et michael
et demi d'euros
avec quatre à cinq entraînements par
semaine les efforts de jade le corps on
pays elle a su saisir la première place
du podium dans la catégorie cadette lors
des championnats de france de cross en
novembre dernier quand je suis parti je
pensais vraiment pas faire podium je
visais un top 5 et bas pendant a comme
je suis vraiment senti bien donc j'ai lu
qu'on commence à détacher des autres
filles donc après je suis parti et
ça a payé spécialisée dans le demi fond
elle a commencé l'athlétisme à 11 ans
performance et chrono surprenant la
jeune femme qui s'entraîne au club de
l'entente athlétique de saint quentin en
yvelines ne cesse d'impressionner
j'ai commencé parce qu'on m'a repéré en
sixième au cross et du coup après je me
suis inscrit au club et je faisais un
peu toutes les spécialités
et après en données géo spécialisé en
demi fond parce que c'est ce que je
préférais début
je m'entraînais comme ça et puis on a
commencé à faire plus d'entraînement a
programmé plus de compet des minimes 2
elle a montré des qualités qui sont
rares arad de quelques dixièmes le
record de france sur 1000 m pour sa
deuxième année de demi fond et puis et
puis l'an dernier 1 cadettes pareil à la
sortie des chronos
très surprenant
ok je m'attendais pas forcément dès que
le coup de feu retentit ça devient c'est
à dire une athlète qui est très forte
mentalement
qui comme je dis qu'il va à la guerre
quand elle a pas peur de la bagarre et
de haies
et chercher l'échiquier vraiment de se
faire mal en compétition véritable
espoir pour la suite jade rêve comme ces
exemples gimmi gressier où hugo est
d'atteindre les jeux olympiques je pense
qu'un ton de faire les jo mais bon je
pense que j'ai le temps et de continuer
à faire des sélections
à mon âge le 1500 et les les jo-2020 de
suite j'aimerai bien los angeles je
pense que j'aurais peut être dans les
meilleures européennes
ouais tu meures europe là dessus de sa
catégorie une motivation à toute épreuve
et des résultats qui suivent la
championne qui fait jusqu'à trois
compétitions par mois pourrait
rapidement gravir les échelons
avant de vous laisser informations
pratiques au 1er janvier 2022 le tri des
déchets évolué à saint quentin en
yvelines désormais dans les poubelles
jaunes vous pourrez trier 100 % des
emballages et des papiers cartons
bouteilles flacons pause sachets fils
mais aussi les emballages en aluminium
et métalliques les emballages en verre
seront toujours eu à déposer dans les
mêmes bac et les ordures ménagères dans
les poubelles grises avant cela pour la
saint sylvestre un petit guide de tri du
réveillon est aussi à votre disposition
sur le site internet de l'agglomération
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité retour de votre
édition d'information locale lundi 10 il
a passé un excellent réveillon de la
saint sylvestre avec prudence bien sûr
belle fin d'année sur tv 78
[Musique]